TO SOCIETY BECOME UNSTABLE WHEN
THERE IS NO ONE AT THE TABLE?
A NEW STUDY LOANS THE SOCIAL
COST OF BEING ALONE.
WALL STREET JOURNAL OWNED BY
PARENT COMPANY, ELMERS GLUE,
POINTS OUT HOW WE ARE SPENDING
LESS TIME BEING SOCIAL AND MORE
TIME BEING ALONE.
I READ IT OVER THE KITCHEN SINK
SPENDING TIME TALKING TO PEOPLE
HAS BEEN IN THE DECLINE FOR
YEARS AND WE ARE FALLING FURTHE
AWAY FROM ONE ANOTHER.
THE MAIN REASON IS THAT HUMANS
ARE EXHAUSTED, WHICH LEADS ME T
REPLY, IT'S NOT JUST ME.
THINK OF THE EFFORT IT TAKES TO
MEET NEW PEOPLE THERE'S THE
STOCKING, THE CROUCHING BEHIND
BUSHES, CARRIED THAT BAG OF ZIP
TIES AND DUCT TAPE.
THE DOWNSIDE LOST INNOVATION AN
CREATIVITY AND PEOPLE LESS
LIKELY TO SEE OTHER POINTS OF
VIEW THE CAN RESULT IN SUBSTANC
ABUSE AND WATCHING SETH MEYERS.
A SURVEY FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE
PERSON JUST SPENT THREE MEALS A
WEEK WITH LOVED ONES REST OF TH
TIME WITH THEIR FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
IT IS FUNNY.
I HAVE SAID HAVING DINNER WITH
OTHERS IS IMPORTANT WAY TO
CONNECT